let's now do some examples that to test
our understanding of what happens when
we multiply or divide a bunch of
positive or negative numbers together
and like always pause the video and see
if you can work through it on your own
before i do it
so first question
what is the sine of s to the 67th power
divided by t to the ninth power
divided by
the expression 3s times s over 4t
when s is less than zero
and t is greater than zero
so the really interesting thing here is
that s is less than zero s is negative
so s is a negative if s is a negative
number a negative we first have s to the
67th power
and we just have to remind ourselves a
negative number
being multiplied if you have an odd
number of negative numbers being
multiplied together you're going to have
a negative number
and s to the 67th power that's 67 s's so
it's literally s times s times s and
you're literally going to have 67 of
these s's and you're multiplying them
all together so you have an
odd number of s's an odd number of
negative numbers that you're multiplying
together so if you have an odd number of
negative numbers multiplied together
well that means that the product is
going to be negative so this thing right
over here is going to be negative
now what's t to the ninth well t is a
positive number they tell us that they
tell us that t
is greater than zero well a positive
number really to any power however many
you have them multiplied together with
an even or odd if it's just all positive
well this is going to be positive so
this thing right over here is going to
be positive now what's a negative
divided by a positive
well a negative divided by a positive is
going to be negative we've already seen
seen that show before so this whole
thing this whole thing maybe i'll circle
it like that is going to be a negative
and so that this thing doesn't get too
messy actually let me let me just
rewrite this so this all of this stuff
that we've written over here i'll just
write this as this is going to be some
negative number
some negative number and then we're
going to divide it by
3s
times s over 4t
now this expression right over here
what is s divided by 4t going to be is
that going to be positive or negative
well we know that s is negative
t is positive so 4 times t is going to
be positive so this thing right over
here is going to be positive
negative divided by positive well that's
going to be a negative so this so
actually let me just write it this way
so all of this stuff i could just
replace with
s divided by 4t is going to be a
negative
so times a negative times some other
negative number now what's 3s well s is
negative so 3s is negative
so that is negative so you have a
negative times a negative which is a
positive
so all of this business right over here
is going to be positive another way you
could think about it is you're going to
have a negative times a negative which
is positive and then divide that by
positive it's just going to be positive
so
so
all of that
so this whole thing all of this business
right over here is going to be a
positive this is all a negative this is
a positive you can have a negative
divided by a positive well that's just
going to be that's going to be negative
so the sign of this crazy expression
right over here it's going to be
negative if s is less than 0 and t is
greater than zero let's keep going this
is fun
all right
so what is the sine
of p times q over p times four and two
sevenths when p is greater than zero and
q is equal to zero and the way i just
stressed q is equal to zero should be a
big hint and let me give you another
hint pause the video if you really think
about what i just said that q is equal
to zero you should be able to do this in
in in less than a second
so why did i say that you could do this
in less than a second
well if you just have a bunch of numbers
and then you multiply them times zero at
some point in that the whole thing is
just going to be equal to zero you know
i could literally have you know a times
b times c times d i could multiply a
bunch of numbers and if i just knew that
one of these numbers is zero then the
whole product is going to be equal to
zero you know if c
is equal to zero i can multiply a times
b times d times e and get some number
and then multiply that times c is going
to be anything times 0 is 0. and notice
q is equal to 0 and q is right over here
so i could take p divided by p that's
going to be 1
1 times q that's just going to be 0 it's
1 times 0 0 and then you have 0 times 4
and 2 7 it's just all going to be 0. and
the key is you're just there's a 0 right
over here at some point you're
multiplying this entire product times 0.
so the whole product is going or you're
multiplying these numbers times zero so
the whole product is going to be a zero
so this sign isn't positive or negative
it's it's zero
all right there's no sign there it's
neither positive nor negative all right
let's do another one what is the sine of
negative 3 4 times negative a to the
fourth over 3 when a is less than 0.
so they're telling us that a is negative
so a is negative
so right over let me do let me use a
more dramatic color
so right over here
i have a negative number to the fourth
power so it's a times a times a times a
and we've already said if you have an
even number of negatives being
multiplied by each other
then that's going to be a positive you
could even see it over here i mean
they're all negative but a negative
times a negative is going to be a
positive a negative times a negative if
i take the third and the fourth one here
that's going to be a positive and then a
positive times a positive what's the
whole thing
the whole thing is going to be positive
even though each of these are negative
negative times negative or another way
you could say a times a is going to be
positive then times a is going to be
negative but then you multiply times a
again it's going to be positive again
so a to the fourth power is going to be
positive
but then you have a negative in front of
it so you're taking the negative of a
positive divided by positive
well so this this all of this this stuff
right over here is all going to be
positive but then you have this negative
in front so this entire thing in front
of the parentheses or inside the
parenthesis is going to be is going to
be a negative
and then you have a negative negative
three-fourths
times a negative well a negative times a
negative the whole thing is going to be
positive so what's the sign of this it's
going to be positive let's do another
one i'm having too much fun
all right
what is the sine of x to the 59th power
divided by 2.3 x times four-fifths when
x is less than zero so x is once again a
negative number
so x to the 59th power that's an odd
number of negatives being multiplied
together
so
this thing right over here is going to
be negative
that's going to be negative right over
there
and this x right over here is going to
be negative
and so 2.3 times that x well that's
going to be negative as well
so this thing is going to be negative
that's going to be negative a negative
divided by a negative is a positive so
all of this business is going to be a
positive
a positive times a positive well that's
just going to be positive
so all of this whole thing is going to
be
is going to be positive
let's i can't stop this is all right
what is the sign of negative x times y
divided by 7 8 and here they're showing
us x and y on a number line and the key
takeaways here is that x is positive x
is to the right of 0
y is negative
y is negative so let's think about this
x is positive but then we're taking the
negative of x right over here so x is
positive but negative of x is going to
be negative you bring a negative number
in front of a positive number that's
going to be a negative number
now what's y divided by 7 8
y is a negative number
y is a negative number i'm dividing it
by a positive number so a negative
divided by a positive is going to be a
negative
so this whole expression this whole
expression right over here is going to
be
negative and then we have a negative all
of this stuff times a negative well
that's going to give us a positive so
the whole thing here is going to be
positive